dans gala merkel a annoncé qu'elle
briguerait un quatrième mandat de
chancelière en allemagne est ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle cet îlot de
stabilité en europe on verra ce sont
toujours les électeurs qui décident en
démocratie et il a une longue campagne
elle s'est déclarée très longtemps avant
eux
comme quoi parfois c'est pas mal de le
faire et c'est une femme qui en tout cas
est tout à fait estimable moi j'ai
beaucoup d'estimé pour elle pour le
courage dont il a fait preuve dans la
crise des réfugiés elle a pris des
risques les paye il ya pu y avoir des
erreurs mais s'est comporté laon
véritable humaniste j'ai de l'estimé
aussi pour justement la façon dont elle
a répliqué avec les valeurs européennes
à l'élection de donald trump je pense
pour le reste que sur le plan économique
et social en allemagne aussi des
inflexions à donner je plaide par
exemple et notamment pour que
l'allemagne soit capable d'investir plus
alors qu'elle a des marges de manoeuvre
budgétaires phénoménal que n'ont pas les
autres et pour elle même et pour le
compte de la zone euro et si j'étais
allemand je suis social démocrate en
france je serai aussi social démocrate
en allemagne mais c'est une femme qu'il
faut respecter et qui apporte beaucoup à
l'europe